With the release of this fall's Joker starring
Joaquin Phoenix, we'll see the debut of the
latest theatrical take on one of the most
iconic comic book supervillains ever created.
But believe it or not it turns out that Phoenix
could've been cast in the role of a completely
different legendary bad guy...not for DC,
but for Marvel.
That's the word according to Charlie Wen,
former head of visual development for Marvel
Studios, and the guy who led the team in charge
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe's whole visual
design.
You may have heard that Phoenix famously turned
down the role of Doctor Strange back in 2014
— a part that eventually went to Benedict
Cumberbatch.
But before that, apparently he was also one
of the Hollywood A-listers to audition for
the role of the Red Skull in 2011's Captain
America: The First Avenger.
According to Wen, who tells us that he had
created a couple versions of Phoenix in the
role, the actor, quote, "definitely could
have added a quirky/creepy feel to Red Skull."
If you're wondering about just what Phoenix
as the Red Skull would've looked like at least
while the comic book villain still wore his
human skin look no further than the exclusive
concept art Wen provided to Looper.
One thing that stands out in this image immediately
is Phoenix's youth.
About 14 years younger than Hugo Weaving,
Phoenix as the Red Skull would've been much
closer in age to Chris Evans' Captain America.
Would a closer age gap have made a difference
to how it felt to watch Captain America beat
up the Red Skull?
Does the Red Skull need to be older and have
a claim on more wisdom and experience than
Cap to be more convincingly threatening?
Maybe!
Then again...maybe not!
But more important than all that, it's not
hard to see that Wen captured Phoenix's quiet
intensity pretty easily in his mock-up.
The look in his eyes clearly communicates
the kind of authoritarian lunacy that can
only radiate off of the leader of HYDRA.
"Hail Hydra."
"HAIL HYDRA!"
It's really fun to imagine how Phoenix's hyper-focused
take on the Red Skull might've affected the
overall film.
However, Wen points out that such an intense
villain might not have actually served the
film very well as a whole.
"I think he would probably have stood out
more than was called for in that role.
[...] Hugo [Weaving], on the other hand, brought
out a Red Skull that was pretty much just
right for the story at the time and for where
Marvel was in that point in the MCU, one that
isn't making too large of a statement for
the role."
That makes sense, when you think about it.
Captain America: The First Avenger is a period
piece, an origin story, a family-friendly
war movie, an adventure film, and a set-up
for one of the biggest crossover films the
Avengers ever made up to that point.
Weaving's turn as a coolly evil supervillain
slots in perfectly, providing just enough
bad guy charm to keep things moving along,
and never distracting too much from the movie's
various missions.
Meanwhile, Joaquin Phoenix could've very well
stolen the show.
That'd be great for the actor, but maybe not
so awesome for The Avengers, which needed
to have audiences already rooting for Captain
America by the time he first shows up on screen
in the modern age.
"I gotta say, it's an honor to meet you, officially.
I sort of met you.
I watched you sleeping."
So while we could mourn the Red Skull we never
got, we might be better off getting excited
for the Joker we will have by the end of the
year.
With just a few photos and one trailer, Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker, directed by Todd Phillips,
has gotten tons of fans buzzing.
Poke around on the internet for just a few
minutes, and you'll see no shortage of hot
takes saying that Phoenix's Joker has the
potential to outshine even Heath Ledger's
legendary turn as the villain.
Wen, for his part, agrees.
"The world of the Dark Knight has been established
as a much darker take on comic book storytelling
and again one that is perfect for both Batman
and the Joker.
Phoenix is one of the few A-list actors that
I can see possibly living up to the iconic
Joker that Heath Ledger gave us."
Overall, Wen thinks the world is much better
off with Phoenix putting his stamp on the
Joker, explaining, "I think he's perfect for
the current Joker film that he's in.
He's such a fantastic character actor."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
supervillains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.